-First team to win
two rounds wins the game.
Let's take our positions.
Andy, you go here.
Bryce, you're over there.
Yeah.
Oh, Bryce, that's Gigi.
Gigi, Bryce.
Yeah.
-It is.
-Well, okay.
First team to win
two rounds wins the games.
Here we go.
Andy, why don't you press --
-I just want to say,
this is so fun, man.
It's so great
to be here with you guys.
I don't care who wins.
-I do.
-What?
-Yeah, we do.
-I do, too.
-Yeah, we care.
-Andy, you have to care
who wins.
-Alright, let's [bleep] do it.
-Andy and I are about to
play a game of "Catchphrase."
We're going to need
some partners.
Andy, we found
a good one for you.
She's a hugely successful
international supermodel.
Please welcome Gigi Hadid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How are you? Pleasure.
-Yes.
-That's Andy.
-You ready?
-Yes.
-We got this.
-That's your partner.
-Yeah.
How come you're not my partner?
We could have -- Yeah.
Joining my team --
oh, I got a good one --
is last year's unanimous choice
for MVP in the National League.
Everyone, please
welcome right fielder
for the Washington Nationals,
Bryce Harper!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah, that's right.
What's up?
Yeah, we good?
-We're so competitive right now.
-Yeah, already.
That's what's up.
That's the way it works, yeah.
-Throwing shade.
-Here's how the game works.
Andy, you're going to start the
game by pressing "start"
on this buzzer
and then drawing a clue
from the top of the pile.
You get your teammate, Gigi,
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture and say anything.
You can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
-Okay.
-A lot of instruction.
-Any gesture, any word
but the clue.
-Yeah. I mean,
you can do whatever you want.
-I can say the thing --
-You can say the clue.
-Okay, great, great.
-Say, "This is the clue."
I'll let you slide in a couple.
First team to win two rounds
wins the game.
Let's take our positions.
Andy, you go here.
Bryce, you're over there.
Yeah.
Oh, Bryce, that's Gigi.
Gigi, Bryce.
Yeah.
-It is.
-Well, okay.
First team to win
two rounds wins the games.
Here we go.
Andy, why don't you press --
-I just want to say,
this is so fun, man.
It's so great
to be here with you guys.
I don't care who wins.
-I do.
-What?
-Yeah, we do.
-I do, too.
-Yeah, we care.
-Andy, you have to care
who wins.
-Alright, let's [bleep] do it.
-Come on.
-Alright, you start, buddy.
Hit the buzzer and go for it.
-And I hit it
and then snag a thingy.
-Yep. Go for it.
-Okay, and hit. Snag it.
Beyoncé's last record
is called...
-"Lemonade."
-Boom.
-Oh, my gosh. Now you pass it.
Snapping.
-What they use for concerts.
-Tickets.
-After -- No.
-Tickets. What? Oh, microphone.
-But he throws it on the ground.
-Drop the mic.
-Boom.
-Hey, is that it?
-You got it.
-Okay, what's another word
for New York?
It's a fruit.
-The Big Apple.
-Yes.
-Okay, this is
a type of stretching.
Downward dog.
-Yoga.
Yes, but it's not cold, it's --
-Pilates.
Hot yoga.
-Yes! How did you get hot yoga?
That's awesome.
-When you make the drums
with your mouth, you you do --
-Beatbox.
-Yep.
-You put this around,
like, trophies and stuff
so they don't break, like,
when you're shipping items.
-Oh, bubble wrap.
-Boom!
-Trophies.
Okay, it has the yellow icon --
[ Buzzer ]
It's not --
-Yeah!
-He took too long!
-He took too long.
By the way, we tied.
-He talked about mic drop
for like three minutes.
-We got it at the same --
-Wait. We lost?
-No, you just lost 1 point.
Calm down.
-Oh, okay. Okay, sorry.
-Gosh.
-Wait, wait, wait.
-You lose if it's on you?
-Of course.
-Oh, then I'm going to
take forever on my question
and then give a great clue right
at the end and then pass it.
-I was going to do something.
You can't...
♪ Turn back time ♪
It already happened, dude.
What do you wrap around
trophies when you ship them?
What do you wrap around trophies
when you ship them?
-Bacon!
-Cher, apparently.
-Oh, here we go.
Gigi, you start us off
on this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I have to press -- Okay.
-Yeah, you press
and start this one off.
Here we go.
Bryce, if we do this again,
buddy, we're champs.
-Okay, Top. It's a noodle.
It's --
-Ramen.
-Yeah.
-Ooh-hoo!
Okay.
This is Zayn's big hit song.
-"Pillow Talk." "Pillow Talk"?
-Yes!
-If you have a little accident
with your car,
and you bump into the back,
it's a...
-Oh, a fender...
Fender bender.
-Yeah.
-Oh! Alright.
-Campfire, what you eat
at a campfire.
-Marshmallows.
-Yes.
[ Audience groans ]
-Uh...
-Toasted marshmallows?
Roasted marshmallows?
-Okay.
They play it -- It's
an instrument with a thing.
It has a thing, and you, like...
[ Vocalizes ]
You guys, I can't make
the sound.
-Bagpipes?
-Yes!
-What?! How did they
get bagpipes?
Okay. At the big dance at
the end of high school.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, come on!
-Yes!
-What was it?
-It was prom queen.
Oh, I didn't go to high school,
so I wouldn't know anyways.
-Yeah. Yeah.
What you wrap
around trophies when you
send them to each other.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, we got it. We got it.
-Dude, it's like looking in
a mirror.
It's like looking in
a mirror, man.
-Unreal.
-I don't own one trophy.
-Who is it that
asked you to prom?
Prom queen.
-Ready for this? Here we go.
-Hottest cheerleader.
[ Laughter ]
We had similar lives as our
partners, don't we?
Alright. Here we go.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole shebang.
This wins the whole shebang.
-Alright. Andy...
-Yeah?
-Focused?
-You got me?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Bryce, we can do this.
[ Beeping ]
Oh. A song from "Rocky III."
It's by the band Survivor.
-Oh, my gosh.
"Eye of the Tiger."
-Yes! That's what it is.
My man! Yes!
-When you type a word
and you spell it --
-Autocorrect.
-Yeah.
-"Eye of the Tiger"? Come on.
-Oh, my gosh.
-"Rocky III"?
[ Laughter ]
Are you kidding me? Um...
Oh, man.
-Just go for it, man!
We got to win!
-Can I pass?
-Take a lap.
-Is that a --
-No, do it!
-I don't even know. Um...
Uh...
I don't know. That's terrible.
I have no idea.
-You have no idea.
You have no clue.
-No clue how to even say this.
-Is it an action?
-No, it's an animal.
-It's an animal. It's a dog.
It's a Rottweiler.
-A dam. They build dams.
-It's what? A beaver.
-Boom!
-What the...
Oh, who we just said!
-Yes! Do we get a buzzer?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Andy!
-He did it! He did it!
He did it on purpose!
-I did it on purpose!
-He did it on purpose
and wasted the clock!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, I'm so happy!
Our thanks to Andy Samberg,
Gigi Hadid, Bryce Harper.
-That's right.
-You're a smart dude.
Everybody, I am here
with Jim Parsons!
And he stars along with
the great Steve Martin
and the great Rihanna in the
big new animated movie "Home,"
which is in
theaters Friday, March 27th.
Jim and I are teaming up
for a game of "Catchphrase."
But, first, we need opponents.
-Yes.
-This guy is a great actor.
He's currently starring in
"The Divergent Series:
Insurgent."
Say hello to Miles Teller,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Best of luck in the game.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Miles is playing with
tonight's musical guest.
He's a hip-hop superstar.
Here is Wiz Khalifa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Good to see you, man.
Thank you for coming back.
Wiz, Jim. You know Wiz?
-Hi.
-What's up, dude?
-Good luck in the game.
-How you doing?
Miles, Wiz. Wiz, Miles.
-We met.
-What's up, man?
-Yeah.
Here's how the game works.
Miles, you're going
to start the game
by pressing "start"
on this buzzer here
and then drawing a clue
from the top of the pile.
You get your teammate, Wiz,
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
and then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture and say anything,
but you can't say any word
in the actual --
Do you remember when
we played Pictionary?
-Yeah.
-If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
First team to win two rounds
wins the game.
Let's take our positions.
I'll go here.
Jim, you go here.
-Oh, I see.
-Yeah, yeah.
Miles, you're here.
Is that right?
Wiz is over here?
-Okay.
You're on that side.
Alright.
Jim, we can do this.
Do we have a special handshake
or something?
-Oh. That's nice.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Alright, very good.
-That's a winner's handshake
right there.
-They won the handshake.
They won the round.
Alright, Miles, press "start"
and then draw from
the top of the pile.
Good luck to everyone.
We have a fun, fair game.
-And go.
[ Beeping ]
Okay, this is something
that when you hike up
somebody's underwear,
and they can't --
-Wedgie.
-Yep.
-Oh, gosh. This is good.
-I don't press it again, right?
-Nope. This is -- Oh, we don't
use these anymore,
'cause we have i...
-Phones.
-We used to have...
-Cellphones. Old phones.
-Gymnasts like to do...
-Flips? Rolls.
-So, wait -- No.
-Roll.
So, the gymnasts do a what?
-Tumble.
-The first thing you said.
-Flip.
-Yes.
-Flip phone!
-Oh, man.
It's a good movie.
It's my favorite movie.
Samuel L. Jackson and
John Travolta.
-"Pulp Fiction."
-There you go.
-That's what's up.
-Oh, my God. Oh!
Yabba-dabba-doo!
-Fred Flintstone!
Fred Flintstone!
-Okay, this is when you do --
What's this called?
-Jumping jacks.
-Yep.
-Oh, went up the waterspout.
Who?
-Spider. Itsy-bitsy spider!
-Something that you search for
at the end of a rainbow.
-Pot of gold.
-There you go.
-Uh...
[ Buzzer ]
-Hammer's pants!
Was it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It was the Cabbage Patch,
was it?
-No, close. Stop! Hey!
-What is that called?
Running Man!
-I was gonna say Running Man.
I was Running Man.
-Oh, I hate this.
-Gosh!
-What do we play to? Two?
-Two.
-Yes, two rounds. Two rounds.
-My heart is beating.
Okay, this is --
-And it's definitely the most
intense game of "Catchphrase"
I've ever played in my life.
-Alright, come on.
Jim, let's catch up.
Here we go. Ready?
-Partly my fault. Yep.
[ Beeping ]
-Okay -- Oh, man!
Okay. Uh...
-Karate! Kung Fu!
-And not a frog, but a...
[ Laughter ]
Like --
-A turtle?
-Yes!
-Karate turtle.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles!
-Yes!
-Okay, this is
a Taylor Swift song.
She's, you know,
doing this thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Come on, tell us this.
-Not -- The last word's
not on, but...
-Off?
-So --
-Just name
10 Taylor Swift songs.
-"Dance-off"?
-With a salt...
-"Shake It Off"?
"Shake It Off."
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah.
-At sea, they take over ships.
They take over ships --
dramatically, with guns.
-Yes, I know.
-They're called...
-Takeover.
-No!
And this is a cheesy snack
that you can --
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, my God!
-Triscuits. Triscuits.
Oh, you won.
You guys -- How did you get
"Shake It Off"?
I'm sorry.
Our thanks to Jim Parsons,
Miles Teller, Wiz Khalifa,
the champs!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're the best, man.